bene abbiamo fatto ho fatto che è che
chi chi chi è
ho fatto delle reaction amari a vari
video in tutti questi video ci sono io
vedrete che cambierò felpa ogni tre
secondi questo video perché queste
reaction losno girate tutte quante in
giorni diversi
quindi partiamo con la prima di oggi un
video di nick bello fatto questo video
dove diciamo ha trovato un escamotage
per superare la quarantena e per
abbracciarci nonostante lavoro interno
ci siamo let's go però la puoi togliere
la mascherina
perché dovrei togliere perché non serve
ma non ce l'ho adesso si dice lei
aspetta te la do io e luigi ha chiamato
su facetime l'altro tra l'altro di
fagioli interessa cosa tutti quanti sul
web sui giornali i vecchi scrivono fa
vigeva di tutto minuscolo e la j
maiuscola senza la solita roba che non
si capisce come cacchio sia possibile vi
mettono stati mai usl nick bello è
l'unica l'unica persona al mondo che fa
il contrario scrive farli maiuscole la g
minuscola questo è successo
lui mi ha chiamato in video chiamata e
mi ha detto tu inquadrati e io faccio
delle cose che poi vedrai e sto vedendo
adesso c'è lui ha fatto questa cosa che
non lo sapevo neanche che immaginavo ma
non me l'aveva neanche detto
diamo mai eccolo ho dormito un'ora
quindi fantastico che mi sta registrano
in condizioni pessime ottimo no io ti
viene molto bene e sono felice
in questo momento di poterti stringere
una marte allora come sono fatto bene
anch'io vorrei tanto francia che non ci
sono i decreti bellissimo perché io
guardo di la mano io guarda la tv
grillo ma rispettare non posso farlo noi
invece noi possiamo abbracciarci anche
se ci sono i decreti
ok in che modo adesso tutti stanno
facendo le videochiamate ma la gente non
si può toccare
non si può abbracciare non si può
stringere la mano ma guarda guarda lo
guardo che facchetti situazione strada
poteva dirvi che stava di là non
guardano dall'altra parte stare non si
può stringere la mano e ho inventato
abbracciare i miei amici e stare con
loro sono avere un contatto fisico
stringerli la mano abbracciato in quegli
fammi indovinare tu hai legato un ipad
ma una specie di pupazzo stai
abbracciando in questo momento quindi tu
in questo senso 6 la faccia il corpo e
qua ti devi fidare di me che sommati
muovo io mi fido ok adesso io ti prendo
in braccio e ti abbraccio quindi io ti
abbraccio se sei felice miste
abbracciandosi senato il 5 guarda la mia
faccia non ha un senso che io abbia
questa faccia durante un abbraccio loro
senso che crisi bellissima donna davanti
a te viola batte mattino cinque
atc che buy sono molto contenta
l'amicizia con te mi rende sempre più
bello guardo io ho un progetto sotto la
pianta del piede che mi sta uccidendo la
scarpa non hai le dita dei piedi non
sappiamo
basta basta basta
nei fianchi non lo patisce 9 bianchi non
lo patisco aspetta fi per una roba
voglio vedere se sei flessibile ok
e quando mi dal pugno io reagisco un'ora
dopo
guarda voglio vedere senza finire mai
ok d'accordo ma io che un sacco di tempo
a questo punto la madonna aspetta anche
l'altra che bello sai che a monte ci
sembra reale marca vacca se ti chiami
qualcosa madonna mi ricorda quando mia
mamma mi faceva addormentare
[Musica]
io non ho mai girato niente di più
kringe però mi piace da morire se ti
lasci qua
mira e buonanotte mi fa impressione
perché sembra troppo ma dove va preso
quel pupazzo poi dove alle cuffie l'ha
tolto
io ho fatto così perché mi immaginavo se
ne fosse andato facendo qualcosa e
quindi ho potuto fare così io credo che
nick sia la persona più creativa non lo
sto dicendo perché gli voglio bene
perché sono proprio io stimo le persone
anche lavorativamente parlando nick è la
persona più creativa che io abbia mai
conosciuto la mia vittoria veramente
sincero voglio salutare anche pancho che
era il suo il suo compagno di avventure
che io ho conosciuto e sicuramente gli
ha dato tanto e adesso pancia non c'è
più ma siamo vicini a nick perché
sappiamo anche lui ea persona forte a
quanto vedo la sua creatività
continua a volare 6 punto di riferimento
per tutti noi nick davvero ne avanti
signori passo la parola al famigie un po
di tempo fa che ha fatto una reaction su
un'altra cosa che voi avete visto signor
fa vj del tempo passato introduci cielo
le televendite di laurent do è stato
come coronare un sogno per me fare
questo video stiamo vedendo se questa
può diventare una serie fatemi sapere se
volete il continuo per caso supportate
il video guardatelo anche un'altra volta
logicamente di virus e facciamo altri
episodi da primo fan di questa serie
quando ho visto la puntata ho fatto la
reaction ok e quindi quella che state
per vedere adesso è una reaction dio che
guardo per la prima volta la puntata di
law rando che voi avete già visto ma la
puntata che io ho guardato che guarderà
in questo video non era il video finale
ma era il video con meno cose tagliate
15 st che voi vedendo il video di adesso
vediate delle scene che non ho messo poi
nel video che avete già visto quindi ci
saranno anche scene nuove spero che vi
piaccia questo ero io che reagivo
adorando la prima volta buona visione
le televendite migliorando 321 io non so
non ho visto ancora giuro non l'ho visto
però vediamole
era ora perché ad oggi vi vende tutto
quello che volete vi vende tutto la
regia che ha acceso le luci vi sono
parti nei primi 10 secondi vi sono
partite le cuffie in una maniera che non
sa neanche dirmi pro ok che ve lo posso
vendere anche questo è l'oggetto cosa
sto vedendo cosa sto vedendo ciò il
fringe che mi esce dal cervello
avete mai provato ad utilizzare lo
smartphone sotto il sole
migliorando ci ho provato però sotto il
sole ci sono i problemi non vedo mai lo
schermo a a voi non vedete mai lo
schermo perché il sole è più grande
nemico di tutti noi global warming greta
tombeur un casino e noi come risolviamo
questo problema come ve lo risolvono
rando che lo risolve così con la pinza
con lo smartphone ai ragazzi ma che cosa
sto guarda chi vi prego queste sono le
cose che uno guarda quando aprile crisi
è di tipo quando andate a dormire
avranno riusciti a dormire vi trovate
alle 3 del mattino come che scorre the
dawn di youtube queste sono le cose
queste sono le cose e siamo solo al
terzo minuto ne mancano sette voglio
morire
vado a inquadrare giorgio stretto vicino
forte ok se ad un primo appuntamento
comincia a piovere leggi cosa sto
vedendo mai azzurri quello marco
i ragazzi di tutto lo potete mettere
ovunque guardatelo tirato fuori
manco fossi jack nobile perché è un
oggetto del genere ma quanto può costare
lo random può costare tantissimo è un
oggetto innovativo
quindi possiamo venderlo mai a 150
ma oggi non lo vendiamo a 150 possiamo
venderlo a 100 ma neanche 100 ragazzi
oggi oggi ve lo dico ve lo dico
signori
799 questo lo vediamo a 7 no ti prego di
farmi operare se io io non so come siamo
finiti a questo punto se nella mia vita
uno mi avesse c'è io comunque ho fatto
l'itis se qualcuno che avesse detto
durante la mia carriera scolastica
secondo me se lo sai che finirà in
questo modo cioè io avrei detto che il
quale fantasy diciamo di inquadrare
schifano giorgio ed all'inizio del video
che inquadri schifano e basta schifano
lo vediamo in un altro episodio
voi dovete schiacciare linking
descrizione imperdibile ci sono solo
pochi pezzi solo chi lo fa adesso riesce
a prenderlo file finalmente giorgio
fatto anche l'inquadratura giusta è che
la volete perdere e non la perdete
questa inquadratura non perdete
l'oggetto della vostra vita linking
descrizione schiacciatelo tutti chiamate
la nonna chiamate vostra mamma
tutti devono schiaccia la descrizione
tutti devono prendere 0 che senza di
esso non riesce a esistere uno
smartphone
il sole è diventato un problema
risolvete lo con zero linking
descrizione ragazzi e comunque laurent
dovi vende sempre cose
incredibilmente utili quindi tranquilli
non vi sto prendendo in giro
l'oggetto è meraviglioso spegnete tutto
linking descrizione via così devi
chiudere giorgio non sai fare un cazzo
ma che cos'è che appena guardato io non
penso sia l'apice del kringe detto
questo ragazzi fortunatamente le
reaction di oggi non finiscono qua
perché abbiamo anche la seconda
non so se vi ricordate tempo fa avevo
chiesto di partecipare a questa
challenge la sorta di una sorta di
challenge non so come spiegarlo vi
spaventa kartoffeln vediamo che cosa
avete tirato fuori dalle vostre idee
insomma i vostri capolavori voglio
vedere come son fatti vediamo i subito
eccoli qua ragazzi spaventa cartoccio e
ci siamo
dal primo let's go sono curioso di
vedere cosa avete tirato fuori da mons
va beh ovviamente più pietro tra tutti
mi sa che era il più scontato però beh
ci stava come partenza va bene ok questo
gel animava d'ora un sacco bellissimo
aspetto
ecco questo è fatto benissimo ha svelato
animale tratto da lui si incanali e cube
all inter fuori casa bravo bravo
sponsorizzati fi sto bene mi è piaciuto
bravo questo hai fatto bene alle clash
da skate reale clash e quindi ragazzi
questi erano i vostri lavori meno male
che c'è un pieno di montevideo perché
sennò sarebbe un casino vorrei dire che
comunque i capelli kartoffeln secondo me
sono tra tutte queste cose è proprio
quello che fa paura quindi
effettivamente in termini nei capelli
poteva avere un senso di tutto questo
quindi ci poteva stare un po il video
iscrivetevi al canale ci vediamo alla
prossima reaction di robe che non ho
ancora visto su di me sempre bello per
scoprire come mi montano gli altri no
aspetta frase però questa è un po
[Musica]